[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله قالت شركه
استشارات الطاقه الامريكيه ان الولايات
المتحده اصبحت اكبر منتج للنفط في العالم
متخطيه بذلك السعوديه في تغيير واضح لشكل
سوق العالمي لاحد اهل المنتجات
الاستراتيجيه الدوليه
نتوقف مع هذا الخبر لنناقشه في محورين هل
زياده الانتاج الامريكي تعني تراجعا في
اهتمام واشنطن بقضايا الشرق الاوسط وهل من
تداعيات سياسيه
متوقعه قد تؤثر على الدور العربي في صناعه
القرار الدولي
في عام الف وتسعمائه وثلاثه وسبعين اوقفت
الدول العربيه تصدير النفط لامريكا والغرب
بسبب دعمهما لاسرائيل خلال حرب اكتوبر مع
كل مصر وسوريا ويقول محللون ان هذا الموقف
كان اللحظات التي بدا الغرب يفكر فيها
جديا في عدم الاعتماد على النفط العربي
ورغم الخلافات بين الحزبين الجمهوري
والديمقراطي في قضايا عده الا انهما
يتفقان على ضروره تقليل الاعتماد على
الخارج في مجال الطاقه
مستورد النفط الاول اصبح منتجه الاول
فواشنطن ازاحه الرياضه كما يبدو عن عرش
البترول العالمي واذا صح التقديرات شركه
استشارات الطاقه الامريكيه فان الانتاج
الامريكي من سوائل الغاز الطبيعي والوقود
الحيوي زاد بثلاثه ملايين ومائتي الف
برميل يوميا منذ عام الفين وتسعه وهذه
اكبر زياده الانتاج في فتره اربع سنوات لم
ينتج السعوديه في الفتره بين عامي سبعين
واربعه وسبعين وقالت الوكاله ان متوسط
انتاج الوقود السائل في الولايات المتحده
سيبلغ اثني عشر مليونا ومائه الف برميل
يوميا خلال العام الحالي تشير تقارير
امريكيه اخرى الى ان صادرات واشنطن ستزيد
على ما تستورده بحلول عام الفين وثلاثين
لتصل الى مرحله الاكتفاء الذاتي بعدها ب 5
اعوام غادرت امريكا بالفعل موقعها ك اكبر
مستورد للنفط في العالم لتحت له الصين وهي
الان تحقق ثاني اكبر طفره نفطيه في
التاريخ بفضل الزياده اللافته في الانتاج
من الاحتياطيات الصخريه الا يحق للعرب ان
يقلقوا بيومين صرف فيه الامريكيون عن
نفطيه ما ابعد ايا من هذه عن تلك التي
حرمت فيها الدول العربيه امريكا والغرب
قبل اربعين عاما من النفط على خلفيه
دعمهما لاسرائيل في حرب اكتوبر لا غربت ان
الحادثه ولدت هوسا غربيا بضروره التحرر من
النفط العربي تتسارع الخطه الامريكيه نحو
ذلك ما قد يعني بحث واشنطن عن حلفاء جدد
في مجال الطاقه لكن هل س يعني ذلك في الشق
السياسي والاستراتيجي تقليل نفوذ الولايات
المتحده في المنطقه وتراجع الاهتمام
بقضايا ها في واحد من اجتماعات منظمه اوبك
المتوجهه من ثوره النفط الصخري الامريكيه
شخص وزير النفط الخليجي للحاله تحدث عن
تاثير معدلات الانتاج الامريكي على صادرات
الخليج لكنه قال ان الامر يفوق ذلك الى
تغيير ثامن في خريطه الطاقه العالميه
وموازين القوه الراهنه في المنطقه والعالم
موضوع حلقتنا نناقشه من عمان مع جواد
العناني الرئيس مركز البصيره دراسات
الاقتصادي اقتصاديه ومن لندن مع ممدوح
سلامه الخبير النفطي والمستشار في البنك
الدولي لشؤون النفط والطاقه مرحبا ب
ضيفينا الكريمين اه اه دكتور جواد انا
لماذا الان اصبحت الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه اه اه الاولى في العالم في
انتاج النفط ما المتغيرات التي ادت الى
ذلك وما معنى ان تصبح الاولى في العالم في
تجربه
اعتقد ان ارتفاع اسعار النفط جعل مكان
الولايات المتحده من القيام بامرين الامر
الاول هو اه البحث عن الابار القديمه التي
كانت قد اوقفت بسبب وصولها الى مستوى
الهامش الذي لا يجعلها منتجه اما الان بعد
ارتفاع اسعار النفط فقد عادت الولايات
المتحده الاستثمار تلك الابار التي كانت
قد اهملت لفتره طويله والموضوع الثاني
والصخر الزيتي الذي تتوفر منه كميات كبيره
من المتوقع ان الولايات المتحده قد بدات
في تسهيل اه هذه الصخور والحصول على اه
نفط منها اه كذلك هنالك بحث جاد عن الغاز
خاصه في ما يزال مشروع الاسكان طبعا تحت
تحت ال اه التنفيذ ولكن هذه كلها ادت الى
زياده اه قدره الولايات المتحده على
الانتاج اه بفعل الظروف الاسواق الدوليه
هذا هذا الشق الاقتصادي لكن السياسي لذلك
المعنى السياسي طبعا هو ان الولايات
المتحده اه سوف اه تكون في موقف افضل
للتفاوض في مجال اسواق النفط وان كان هي
موقفها الان قوي جدا لان السوق الامريكيه
اه كميه الاحتياطي التي في نقص الاحتياطي
ارتفاع الاحتياطى اه طلبها مؤثرات الطلب
على فيها هي التي كانت ال المتغير الاساسي
الذي يحدد اسعار النفط في العالم اه ولذلك
اعتقد بان هذا الدور الله مرشح لان يصبح
اكثر قوه مما كان عليه في السابق
كيف ستستفيد الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
من هذا الواقع الجديد باعتبارها الان او
ال او ل او اكبر منتج للنفط في العالم اه
وهي التي تعاني من ازمه اقتصاديه
اه دعني اولا افرد بعض الحقائق بالنسبه
لانتاج الولايات المتحده الولايات المتحده
رام الادعاءات من قبل وكاله الطاقه
الدوليه ومن قبل اجهزه الاعلام الامريكيه
لم تسبق السعوديه او روسيا في انتاج النفط
انتاج الولايات المتحده الحالي بما فيه
الغاز السائل هو سبعه ونصف مليون برميل في
اليوم فاذا ما اضفنا اليها انتاج انتاجها
من الايثانول اه وهو حوالي مليون وربع فان
انتاجها الكل ما زال اقل من السعوديه واقل
من روسيا ثم هناك ناحيه اخرى اه كلفه
الانتاج الامريكي نحتاج الى اثنين وسبعين
لثمانين دولار للبرميل الواحد
وهناك ظاهره عجيبه وهو ان ان نزف او
النضوب المتسارع في ابار النفط
التي ينتج منها النفط من الصخر الزيتي
اي ان في كل بئر منذ منذ بدء الانتاج في
السنه الاولى يحدث
او نضوب يساوي سبعين
في التفاصيل
اريد ان اسال هنا و افهم لماذا شركه شركه
الطاقه الامريكيه بيره يعني تنشر هذا
الخبر وتقول بان الولايات المتحده اصبحت
اكبر منتج وتخطط بذلك السعوديه ما الهدف
من ذلك
لانها
لانها شركه اولا شركه امريكيه وثانيا هناك
مجموعه من المؤسسات اضافه الى هذه الشركه
تسعى الى التاثير على سوق النفط العالمي
وعلى سعر النفط وللتاثير على دول الخليج
المنتجه للنفط باظهار عن الولايات المتحده
سبقها ان لم تكن قد سبقتها هذا لم يحصل
حتى الان من الممكن في السنوات القادمه ان
يرتفع انتاج الولايات المتحده بما يساوي
السعوديه ولكنه لن يبقى عند ذلك الحد لان
النضوب السريع يجعل الانتاج الامريكي في
انخفاض في عام من من يبدا في الانخفاض من
عام الفين وعشرين ومنازل وقد يصل الى فقط
الى سته واحد بالعشره مليون برميل في
اليوم
سيد جهود ان ان ي اذا صدق اه يعني صدقت
قراءه اه السيد ممدوح سلامه بان شركه
استشارات الطاقه الامريكيه لم تكن صادقه
ولم تكن يعني اه اه اه ربما اه تصف الواقع
الحقيقي لانتاج النفط الامريكي لماذا تنشر
هذا هذا ال هذا هذا يعني هذا التقرير
وباي لاي اهداف سياسيه تعتقد خاصه ما
يتعلق بالشرق الاوسط
اولا اعتقد ان الهدف الرئيسي من نشر هذا
الخبر وهو خبر كان يعد له من فتره يعني
وليس جديد مائه في المائه ولكن اطلاقه في
هذه اللحظه ياتي تماما بعد الانتهاء من
ازمه الموازنه في الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه وتعلمون ان ازمه الموازنه قد
تسبب ضررا
كبيرا سمعه الولايات المتحده الاقتصاديه
فلذلك ياتي هذا الخبر الايجابي معززا
لقدره الاقتصاد الامريكي حتى لا يتجه
العالم فيه خاصه واننا سمعنا من الصين اه
التي تملك حاله اربعه مليون دولار
استثمارات اه في الدولار اه تريد تقول في
ذلك وكذلك سمعنا ايضا بان هنالك مطالبات
باعاده النظر في الدولار كعمله دوليه امام
هذه الامور كلها طبعا ياتي هذا الخبر
معززا سمعه الولايات المتحده في هذا الوقت
بالذات اما اه اه تاثيره على الشرق الاوسط
فلا اعتقد ان له تاثيرا كبيرا على على
اقتصاديات النفط في المنطقه العربيه
والسبب الرئيس هو ان الولايات المتحده لا
تستورد نفط من الدول العربيه الا بكميات
قليله جدا اذا ان معظم استيرادها ياتي من
كندا والمكسيك وفنزويلا ونيجيريا والجزائر
اه والدول النفطيه في منطقه الخليج لا
تزود اكثر من عشره في المائه لكنها
الاتجاه الان والطلب العالمي المتوقع في
المستقبل
من الولايات المتحده ولا حتى من اوروبا ان
ما سياتي من دول اقرب الى دول الخليج وهي
الصين والهند ودول جنوب شرق اسيا ولذلك
اعتقد بانه سنشهد هنالك تحول في بنيه
الطلب على النفط وعلى الغاز في المستقبل
اه من المحيط الاطلسي باتجاه المحيط
الهادئ وهذا والهندي ولذلك يعني يجب في
الوطن العربي ان نبدا الاستعداد لهذا لهذه
الاحتمالات في المستقبل
حتى فرضا لو لو سلمنا بان الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه وصلت الى الحد الذي
اصبحت ربما فيه تنتج ما تنتجه السعوديه او
روسيا هل يعني ذلك بالضروره انها ربما قد
تقلل اعتمادها على النفط العربي
لم تقلل ابدا لان اللفظ العربي هو نفط
الاستراتيجيه بالنسبه للولايات المتحده و
وسيله سياسيه
للتاثير على اوروبا التي تعتمد على النفط
العربي وعلى اه
النفط الافريقي وكذلك وسيله للضغط على
الصين التي منذ اكثر من عشر سنوات كان
الشرق الاوسط هو اكبر مصدر لها انت تعلم
ان الصين هي اكبر مستورد للنفط السعودي
منذ اكثر من خمس سنوات وهي ثانيه اكبر
مستورد للنفط الايراني
وثالثا هي اكبر مستثمر في تطوير النفط
العراقي ووجود الولايات المتحده واساطيلها
في منطقه الخليج اه هي وسيله لضمان النفط
الاستراتيجي العربي بالنسبه للولايات
المتحده و للتاثير على سياسه الصين التي
تعتمد كليه واذا حد كبير على نفط الخليج
وهنا اسال السيد جواد العناني ان هناك راي
يقول بان اكتفاء الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه ربنا من الطاقه بعيدا عن مصادره
في منطقه الشرق الاوسط وخاصه
منطقه الخليج قد يجعل واشنطن اقل رغبه في
الحفاظ او الحرص على الاستقرار في هذه
المنطقه وبالتالي قد اه ترفع غطاها
العسكري عن هذه المنطقه هل هذا صحيح
اه استبعد ذلك كثيرا لان الولايات المتحده
صحيح قد يكون لها هنالك مزيد من الاهتمام
في محورها الباسيفيك ولكن هذا لن يكون على
حساب اهمالها اه لمنطقتنا العربيه اولا
لانها منطقه استراتيجيه تضم اهم ممرات
تجاريه في العالم والامر الثاني انها لم
تضع هذه المنطقه لتجد نفسها صدقات جديده
مع دول اخرى تنافس الولايات المتحده يعني
اه اه ما نراه الان من حرب بارده تجري في
بعض المناطق العربيه مثل سوريا على سبيل
المثال دليل واضح على ان الولايات المتحده
لن تترك يعني اجندتها في منطقتنا ليست
محصوره في قضيه اه في قضيه النفط لانه
محصوره في اسرائيل ايضا محصوره ايضا في
البعد السكاني في الموقع الاستراتيجي في
العلاقات احتماليه تكوين اه اه مستقبل
علاقاتها التي تواجه الصين اه فلذلك
القضيه اه قضيه الشرق الاوسط اهميته لا
تنبع من النفط فقط وانما تنبع من اعتبارات
استراتيجيه كثيره تهم الولايات المتحده
بشكل خاص استكمال ذلك في الموضوع ثلاثه
انت قلت قبل قليل بان العرب اصل المصادر
تهم تتجه الى اه دول منافسه اقتصاديه
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه اه على راسها
الصين وبالتالي هنا نسال اه هل يمكن ان
يفعل ذلك ربما الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
اكثر رغبه في تاثير على اقتصاديات
منافسيها من خلال الرغبه في عدم استقرار
كامل في منطقه اه اه اه النفط العربيه
جوابي على ذلك الصين واقتصاد الصين سيسبق
الولايات المتحده في عام الفين وخمسه عشر
وبذلك هذا له امر مهم امر استراتيجي
الولايات المتحده اقتصاد الصين يعتمد كليا
وبوجه عام على اه استيراد النفط العربي من
الخليج بالذات واي تحول او نقص في هذا
الاستيراد سيؤثر على الصين من هنا تدرك
الولايات المتحده ان الصين الان اصبحت
منافسه ضخمه لها سواءا كدوله اقتصاديه
عظمى او كدوله اقتصاديه نوويه فس تحاول
الولايات المتحده بطريقه او باخرى للتاثير
على تطور الصين السريع
وتحولها نحو قصب السبق او ضد الولايات
المتحده
فبالتالي ستسعى ولو بطريقه او باخرى لضمان
انه في حاله وقوع ازمه في المستقبل بين
الولايات المتحده والصين بالنسبه ل تايوان
على سبيل المثال انها ستحول دون وصول
النفط العربي الى الصين للتاثير على
اتصالها وعلى با كنت ها العسكريه فبالتالي
سيبقى ستبقى الولايات المتحده مركزه على
الشرق الاوسط وستبقى الصين معتمده على نفط
الشرق الاوسط وسنرى ان التنافس بين
العملاقين سيستمر طويلا
ان كان هذا التنافس يصب في مصلحه دول
الشرق الاوسط وخاصه الدول العربيه المنتجه
بعد هذا الفاصل وناقش ايضا هل من تداعيات
سياسيه متوقعه قد تؤثر على الدور العربي
في صناعه القرار الدولي ارجو ان تبقى معنا
مشاهدينا الكرام
اهلا بكم من جديد في هذه الحلقه التي
تناقش الدور العربي في صناعه القرار
الدولي بعد اصبحت الولايات المتحده الاولى
عالميا في انتاج النفط وذلك حسب ما قالت
شركه استشارات الطاقه الامريكيه كبيره وان
كان ضيفنا في الانظمه يستبعد ان يكون ذلك
حقيقه فعلا وان هناك اسباب قد تكون وراء
هذا التقرير نعود الى ضيفينا الكريمين اه
اه سيد ممدوح اه او سواء جواد علي عذرا اه
هذا التنافس الذي تحدث عنه السيد ممدوح في
لندن بين الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
والصين حول النفط العربي هل سيكون في صالح
الدول العربيه المنتجه للنفط ان ان ذلك
سيكون سيعود عليها بنتيجه غير ما تبتغيه
سيؤثر على مساهمتها في القوات الدوليه ام
لا
اه اعتقد بان اه هذا يتطلب مهاره سياسيه
عاليه جدا من قبل الدول العربيه لان
احتماليات التنافس القطبين الاكبر
المدنيين في العالم على النفط الموجود
لديها يعطيها فرصه فرصه متميزه لتحسين
موقفه التفاوضي مع كل القوتين ولكن اه في
الواقع اه اه ان الحياه لا تسير بهذه
البساطه اه بل ربما تمارس دوله كبرى مثل
الولايات المتحده ضغوطا متزايده على الدول
العربيه اه في ظل اه اه ما يجري حاليا في
المنطقه يعني مثلا اذا نظرنا الى خارطه
ايران الجمهوريه الاسلاميه في ايران نرى
انها الدوله التي تصل بين اه بين قوسين
النفط في العالم الاساسيين اللي هما ال ال
الخليج من ناحيه والمنطقه الثانيه طبعا هي
بعرف مين ونعلم ان نصير قادره او فكرتهم
الايام على مد خطوط انابيب ل اه استيراد
النفط اه من دول وسط وسط اسيا اه اه عبر
صحراء غوبي فلذلك
هنالك دراسات كثيره الاحتماليات الان كيف
سيتم اه بلوره اللعبه في التنافس بين اه
ايران من ناحيه ودول
وسط اسيا من ناحيه اخرى وبين مجموعه الدول
العربيه هذا هو السؤال السؤال المهم هذا
هي الاعتبارات التي يجب ان ياخذها السياسي
العربي بعين الاعتبار عندما يريد ان يحقق
لنفسه اه موقفا تفاوضيا قويا اه في
المستقبل
سيدنا اه زياده انتاج النفط الامريكي حتى
لا اقول اه الان الصداره في الانتاج بانك
تستبعد ذلك هل س يعني بذلك بالضروره ونحن
نعلم اه كثيرا من تشدد الاداره الامريكيه
ان لديها مصالح حيويه في منطقه الشرق
الاوسط هل يعني ذلك ربما اه تراجعا في
اهتمام الولايات المتحده الامريكيه بقضايا
الشرق الاوسط هل هذا وارد
اه لن يكون هناك تراجع طالما بقي اسرائيل
في قلب العالم العربي وطالما اه امتلكت
دول الخليج العربي ما يزيد عن اربعين في
المائه من الاحتياط المؤكد للنفط في
العالم كما قلت كل الانتاج الامريكي واقول
انه مبالغ فيه بشكل كبير جدا لاغراض
سياسيه اقول ان ال ان لا يمكن تجاهل دول
الخليج العربي باستثناء ايران لانها لديها
واه ناتج اجمالي يزيد عن واحد وسته في
العشره مليون دولار ولديها اربعين في
المائه من احتياطي النفط المؤكد في العالم
فقوه من هذا النوع لا يمكن تجاهلها انما
الولايات المتحده تستفرد دول الخليج واحده
بعد الاخرى اذا مش دول الخليج يدا واحده
فانها قادره على اثبات وجودها في العالم
وسيبقى نفوذها كبيرا اذا احسنت استثمار
سياسه النفط في المستقبل
بالنسبه للولايات المتحده كما قلت لن
تتخلى ابدا عن منطقه الشرق الاوسط طالما
اسرائيل موجوده فيها الولايات المتحده
موجوده لدعم اسرائيل ولحمايه اسرائيل هل
هذا تاثير اه لارتفاع
انتاج الولايات المتحده من النفط سينصب
فقط على دول الخليج والسؤال السيد جواد
العناني سبع دول الخليج فقط ام سيسري على
دول اه عربيه اخرى كبرى في انتاج الافكار
الجزائر وليبيا
قطعا اذا كان سيؤثر على دوله عربيه سيؤثر
على باقي الدول العربيه لكنني اعتقد اننا
يجب ان نتذكر حقيقتين اساسيتين اولا ان
استهلاك العالم من النفط ما يزال رغم
زياده الطلب عليه ما يزال مضغوط يعني لم
يصل الى الحدود التي اه يمكن ان يصل اليها
على سبيل المثال الولايات المتحده معدل
استهلاك الفرد السنوي فيها يصل الى حوالي
سبعه وستين برميل مكافئ من من الطاقه اه
بينما في دول مثل الصين يقل عن عشرين في
دول مثل اللي عند خمسطاشر ولذلك اذا زادت
هذه كل واحده يعني الصين والهند برميل
واحد للفرد في كل سنه هذا سيعني زياده
الطلب العالمي على النفط في هاتين
الدولتين فقط اثنين وسته ال عشره بليون اه
برميل مكافئ ومن هنا فانني اعتقد بانه يجب
ان لا يكون هنالك جزء على الاطلاق من
احتمالات اه بقاء النفط العربي بحجمه
وبكلفه وب نوعيته يجب ان يبقى في الصداره
رغم
وحتى لا خوف على يعني
هذا الواقع على سعر النفط العربيه على
السوق النفسي بشكل ان
اجيب واسمع ارجوك ان تسمح لي دقيقتين
دقيقه واحده كامله لا خوف على سعر النفط
سعر النفط هو في صعود وقد يصل الى مائه
وثلاثين دولار في عام الف اه عشريه الفين
وخمسه عشر
ثم علينا ان نعلم انه ان اه ان ان الطلب
العالمي على النفط مستمر في الصعود خصوصا
من قبل الصين ودول حوض المحيط الباسفيكي
وقد وقد نحتاج ما بين الان وعام الفين
وخمسه وثلاثين اه تسعه امثال انتاج
السعوديه او اربعه وستين مليون برميل في
اليوم حتى نغطي الطلب العالمي فالانتاج
الامريكي كله لا يشكل اكثر من اثنين في
المائه من الامدادات العالميه للنفط الاهم
شكرا لك
استشاره في البنك الدولي لشؤون النفط
والطاقه
كما نشكر ضيفنا من عمان جواد العناني رئيس
المركز البصيره للدراسات الاقتصاديه
ونشكركم مشاهدينا الكرام لمتابعتكم شكرا
لكم والسلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
[موسيقى]
ام